je vous propose artistes que vous ne
saviez pas juif
par l'honneur du plus exceptionnels du
groupe de femmes que j'ai jamais connu
oui je serai prête à tout pour écouter -
écoutez moi je viens d'avoir une idée
dingue je vous ai dit que mon père était
militaire est que c'est pratiquement lui
qui a tué oussama ben laden je suis pas
sûr qu'on savait tout ça mais ok bon ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est un gros
bonnet de l'armée et tous les ans il ya
un spectacle qui monte pour distraire et
réconforter les troupes cette année donc
c'est dj khaled qui présentent ils
adorent un milliard de tubes et il est
super célèbre jeu les vues dans une pub
pour les impôts et si j'arrivais à nous
faire inviter on chanterait non voyons
on serait en mission secrète
d'infiltration oui bien sûr que son
frère elle avait remporté le titre
mondial groupe improbable nom masculin
qui est curieusement parvenu à briller
dans un domaine qui n'a rien à voir avec
la cuisine je vous entends j'ai donné
mal de gens virés évoque toute cette
énergie négative s'évacue ouvre les
jambes elle va sortir plus vite pour que
c'est comme ça tous les ans un concert
est organisé pour soutenir les troupes
en europe
je suis calamity non pas si serenity et
charrie les six mois j'entrais dans le
groupe je pourrais être obesity n'a
jamais affronté des groupes qui ont des
vrais instruments alors c'est quoi le
temps elles ne sont pas à la hauteur des
autres groupes qu'on n'est pas des bouts
fun de service tu es bien sûr est ce que
je t'ai déjà lâché grains de poivre au
thé pas du tout fiable c'est une seconde
nature pour toi ce sera notre dernier
concert ensemble alors qu'une fine le
lieu exceptionnel groupe de femmes
vous aimerez tardy
façon à la catastrophe